this week's been a wild one for bitcoin
obviously we have the russia and ukraine
conflict that continues to play out but
there's many other macro forces at work
we saw a 7.9 cpi print in inflation
numbers and then we also have a ton of
potential questions at the macro economy
level will a recession end up happening
will inflation continue will the fed
hike rates in the month of march nobody
knows but what we do know so we can go
right to the metrics for bitcoin
specifically and we can validate we can
audit it for ourselves so if we go ahead
and do that we can see that bitcoin
right now is trading at 38 768
it's down about half a percent over the
last 24 hours if we then go ahead and
look at the bitcoin specific statistics
what we can see is that that market cap
is about 733 billion or so on top of
that that's about 90 of the supply being
already issued and miners were paid 35.5
million dollars over the last 24 hours
to continue to secure it the most secure
computing network in the world bitcoin's
down about 43 from its all-time high but
it's up about 17 or so from the recent
low if we then go ahead and take a look
at the past performance of bitcoin gold
the s p 500 we can see that bitcoin is
down 32 from 12 months ago that big
price drawdown was because bitcoin was
in the period going from about ten
thousand dollars to sixty four thousand
dollars between the end of 2020 and the
beginning of 2021 this was almost the
peak of exactly where bitcoin peaked out
in march of 2021. if we then go ahead
and we take a look at the rest of the
years two three four five six seven
eight nine ten years or more in bitcoin
gold and s p 500 we can see that bitcoin
has been steadily outperforming all of
these other assets for quite a while and
so if we take a look then at bitcoin's
history we can see that bitcoin has only
been higher than this current price
point six point four percent of the time
that means that about 93 and a half
percent of bitcoin's life has been at a
lower price if you bought bitcoin then
you held till today you are in profit if
we then go ahead and we take a look at
what i think is one of the most
important numbers in all of bitcoin that
compound annual growth rate you can see
that bitcoin continues over the last
decade to compound growth at 143
every year that is an incredible
performance the sharpe ratio of the five
years is still 1.5 or so which puts it
steadily above gold
s p 500 nasdaq or tlt if we then go
ahead and we take a look into will
clemente and block ware's newsletter
this week we've got two on-chain metrics
that we can show you the first is this
percent futures open interest but using
crypto as margin rather than stable
coins or anything else and you can see
that at the beginning of march we
started to see an uptick in that futures
open interest so it's something to
continue to pay attention to as more
leverage enters the system then if we go
and we look at whales what the hell are
the whales doing in bitcoin well we can
see that whales actually in the
beginning of march or kind of end of
february started to sell some of their
coins and what this really tells us is
that bitcoin is becoming more
distributed the whales hold less of it
but also it tells us that that's
probably where a lot of the cell
pressure is coming from even though we
have that geopolitical conflict even
though we have all the macro factors
bitcoin still is trading within this
like 35 to 45 000 range a lot of it's
probably because these whales are
actually have so much cell pressure in
the market and then lastly if we go
ahead and we take a look dylan leclair
had this great tweet that showed that
literally 30 000 bitcoin were taken off
a coin base just yesterday and so
ultimately what we're watching is that
there's a lot of action that's happening
in the bitcoin market but because
bitcoin is an open decentralized
protocol that the blockchain is an
immutable ledger that can be audited by
anyone we can see exactly what's
happening who's buying who's selling and
what those behaviors have in a
relationship to price i continue to
think that bitcoin serves as a great
global store of value it's the only
asset in the world that no one owns no
one controls no one can print more of it
bitcoin in light of all of the
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
is still super attractive to me
personally and as we continue to see all
sorts of censorship and seizures
happening in the various corners of the
economic and financial markets i think
bitcoin more and more people are getting
orange built and they're realizing the
true value that it has that's it for
this week i look forward to talking next
week hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time